um we flew from dallas
okay so we had to take wichita
flight back to dallas and then dallas
back to lax
and dude we get to the airport in dallas
when when we're we're from from kansas
and dude i get there and i look and
there's [ __ ] homies you know what i
mean just like homies like when a when a
group is together at an airport you see
them and you're like oh i like that
they're traveling all together but these
were all dressed in black
all homies and there were like eight of
them right and i look at one of them
they all got masks on now i'm like okay
if you have masks on
in lax
right i i don't even really think i
don't really you know
la is very woke right so if you're going
to wear masks a lot of mass in the
airport right that's okay you're woke
and that's fine it shouldn't be a
political thing if you feel comfortable
wearing a mask inside great more power
to you i think you should i want you to
be comfortable right okay
now if you see masks in dallas airport
something like is different right so i'm
like why are these guys wearing a mask
why why are the homies wearing a mask
right why are these eight homies wearing
masks
because if you see a homies wearing
masks
in dallas
you think okay well yeah sure we are
flying to los angeles so maybe they're
woke but also maybe some extras going on
here
so i do my [ __ ] thing you know how uh
who's the [ __ ] detective uh watson
and sherlock holmes i do my thing where
i quickly gather all the information
just by taking a [ __ ] wide shot of
the people right you ever do that you
ever try to feel information right
because you can do that dude that's the
gift of fear you ever read that book
it's amazing it's about intuition more
specifically women's intuition but i
have women's intuition okay
my i don't we don't label my intuition
my intuition i identify as a woman all
right so my intuition as a woman takes a
wide snapshot of these guys and i
immediately go to oh
this is a hip-hop group now am i racist
we don't know but none of the guys are
black so maybe not but they are maybe
all not white like maybe they're mexican
or cute i don't know what they are
they're not black they're cuban there's
something but i take the snapshot
i take the intuition snapshot
and i decide they're a hip-hop group now
am i racist now what do i do and the
reason why i'm wondering about this is
because maybe they're not wearing the
masks out of wokeness maybe they're
wearing the masks because of why well
they have hoods on they all have
sunglasses on maybe they're doing it to
try to disguise their face which is what
i should be doing because it's super
annoying when people come up to me at
the airport and ask for pictures and
then take videos now
you ask for a pick why'd you take a vid
all good yes for one thing
not the other i acquiesced and now i'm
stuck on video looking like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i gotta smile
so i judge maybe they're famous
and i just maybe they're a hip-hop group
now i'm not racist
but i do a little bit more of i take
more than just the intuition snapshot i
take more than
that i look at them and i decide
i'm 80 sure that they're [ __ ] cypress
hill okay i'm 80 percent sure that
they're cypress hill
so i go
maybe that's be real
maybe that's sendog i've got no idea is
it send dog and be real i don't know
i walk over to my tour manager
he says just see cypress hills here and
i go
ch ching and i know it's cypress hill
number one
because i thought it was cypress hill
and my tour manager said did you see
cypress hill over there but mostly
because
my tour manager is mexican
[Music]
now that was too soft the runner would
knit a little bit
there we go dude
now he's mexican so he knows right
because i have mexican and also like for
some reason persians love cyprus hill
but and they and they and i have persian
friends that love cyprus hill and dude
it was cyprus [ __ ] hill and um
i'm like am i going to become friends
with
be
am i going to become friends with be
real dude
there is something you can't understand
what could just kill a man the two
opposite ends of voices and two [ __ ]
lines there is something you can't
understand hawker just killer man two
opposite ends dude they really had i
didn't know they had so many [ __ ]
hits though dude they're they're their
songs are so cinematic dude their songs
are so cinematic they're in so many
movies
remember this one i want to get ha
so high
remember that one remember this one i'm
having illusions
whatever the [ __ ] remember that one
so many [ __ ] good songs man they
really did dude that one and [ __ ] um
there was another song called lowrider
what's the [ __ ] and then uh cyprus
i'm having the illusions and the be
dusions and the blinkflicks and the
rhymes what else dude uh songs cypress
hill songs
are they from cyprus sounds or some [ __ ]
um this one where the [ __ ] insane and
the membrane insane in the brain and
then it goes insane in the mega and then
i gotta go
[ __ ] high making that song
insane because you got no brain wouldn't
be insane would just be [ __ ] on a
pile of skin on the floor
and then that [ __ ]
plan
you want to be in rock superstar
eminem
live large buy your house five cars and
you're in charge coming up in the world
ever if you don't know that song you're
[ __ ] you got no brain
dude that song was [ __ ]
blank
dude i'm so good at hitting those notes
it's unbelievable you know exactly what
i'm [ __ ] doing when
so you wanna be in rock superstar
if you don't know that song you got no
brain
so
yeah dude
it's killer [ __ ] so now i'm like am i
gonna be friends with be real and also
i'm like we're send dog and for some
reason i got in the back of my head that
send dog quit the group i have no idea
but there was another guy that looked
like he was cuban and it could have been
send dog and that's when i knew i was
racist still not sure if it's sundog and
they're all sitting dude here's the
thing about cyprus still you want some
inside info on cyprus cause i have it
dude
there was like eight of them
all dressed the same
all in black
looking real cool
they were all either in first class or
the one right behind it like with the
plus [ __ ]
and i'm telling you dude there were
eight of them
during the whole flight from dallas to
[ __ ] la
none of them said one word to each other
if that's not the most
cypress hilis ass [ __ ] that you've ever
heard
they didn't say one word to each other
dude
and calvin had a crying fit in front of
the
reel
sat in front of be real and we
my son had two cups of water and kept on
putting one the [ __ ] water in one cup
and a water in another cup water in one
cup watering another cup and i was
overseeing the operation obviously
because this is going to [ __ ] end in
a travesty and i'm like i'm going to do
it until he supposed to do this
dude he kept doing it keeps doing it and
then he spilled a lot all over his
[ __ ] pants dude
and it was annoying as [ __ ] match
because now he can't change his pants
because they're packed and we only have
one diaper right
and so i went to go so i go all right
that's enough and then chris was like
that's enough and then she gave the cups
to throw away to the [ __ ]
air stewardess to throw away
and um
and then and then calvin just starts
crying so hard and right he was sat
right in front of be real and he was
[ __ ] crying so hard dude he was like
i need the cops
but i kept on sneaking looks back to be
real and if that guy was and maybe
whoever that guy was that was maybe
zendog
and he was just [ __ ] crying dude
and i was like calvin you can't just
you're gonna get wet dude you're gonna
keep getting wet
it's like stop being [ __ ] insane in
the membrane dude calvin's can you stop
being insane in a membrane
you're being insane cause you got no
brain
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]